>> Male Presenter: Good afternoon everyone.
My name is Brian Rose.
I'm
from the photos team.
I'm here presenting Thomas Hawk
for part of our photographers at Google series.
Thomas
Hawk is a prolific photographer.
He's here from the Bay
Area.
And one of his life goals is to produce more
than one
million photographs.
He's well on his way there.
If you
are on Google+, you'll probably, or actually
you've almost
certainly seen his photos.
Either re-shared by his
friends, shared in your own stream or in our
"what's hot"
stream.
At 450,000 followers, he's most certainly
one
of our top followed photographers but he's
also one
of our most followed users on Google+.
Last night, he launched his Photo Talk Plus,
Live streamed
hangouts which he co-hosts with Lotus Carroll
every Wednesday
evening and I encourage you to check it out
not just
because I was on there last night.
[chuckles] For a quick bit of
admin, there will be plenty of time for Q
and A but I
encourage you to use the microphones on the
side for the
benefit of our YouTube and video conference
audience.
So
with that, please join me in welcoming Thomas
Hawk for
the photographers at Google series.
[Applause]
>> Thomas: Well, thank you Brian.
And thanks for everybody for
coming out.
I'm glad to be here at Google.
I'm a big
fan of Google's.
I've enjoyed Google+ and all the
great things you guys are doing with photography.
I'm
happy to be here today.
Looking forward to sharing some
photos talking a little bit about just sort
of my vision
in general with photography and how I approach
it, how I
look at it, how I do what I kind of do.
Brian said
yeah -- oh, is that better?
Okay.
Yeah, my goal is to
publish a million photographs before I die
which is a
pretty ambitious goal.
There have been a lot of prolific
photographers over the years.
I've kind of tried to find
out photographers that are doing that much
publishing and
there are not a lot of them out there.
For me, I'm not
sure exactly where that comes from other than
I have a
desire to constantly be active with photography
and see
the world through my camera every single day.
And by
setting a very arduous schedule like that
and a very lofty
goal, it really helps me to be focused constantly
on
photography.
One thing like I would just say everybody
in this room I also have a day job.
I'm not a
professional photographer.
And so, one of the questions
I get a lot is how do you do so many photographs?
How do
you do so much work and still kind of manage
your other
stuff in your life?
And so, I'm going to talk a little
bit about that today and what I do.
In addition to
full-time job, I've got four young kids.
I've got a 7,
8, 9, and 11-year-old.
I've found photography, as
passionate as I am about it, you've really
got to be
incredibly efficient with it and you've got
to make it
work for you in every way.
I'll talk about some of the
things I do to become more efficient in my
own work as
well as, in addition to that, talk about my
-- one of my
projects right now which is to photograph
the 100 largest
American cities.
I've photographed now 31 of the 100 largest
American
cities.
I'm doing more and more each year.
And so, this
year I'm gonna knock off some more.
Route 66 from Tulsa through
Los Angeles.
This year I went to St. Louis and Houston
and Austin and Detroit and a number of other
places.
I'll talk
about those trips and how I plan for those
trips and how
I decide what I'm going to shoot on those
trips and I how I do those trips as
efficiently as I can.
I'm also going to talk a little
bit about my experiences photo sharing in
general.
I've
been online sharing photos for a while now.
I guess I
first started in 2003.
I got involved with Flickr very,
very early and became one of the most active
Flickr
users and one of the most followed users there.
And talk about my strategy with that.
I will say
to start, again like I said before, I'm not
a
professional photographer although I do make
money with
my photography.
It's not my primary source of income.
I
think that for me being able to focus just
on my art as a
nonprofessional photographer affords me certain
luxuries.
And one of those is I don't care a lot about,
you know,
making money with my work.
I don't care if people steal
my work.
You know, everything is licensed creative
commons.
I don't watermark things.
I don't try to
prevent people from getting my stuff.
My goal as an
artist is that people will see my stuff as
much as
possible everywhere.
So because I don't have to worry
about making a living for it, you know, I
think
that's an important distinction.
Also I can shoot what I
want to shoot and I can really focus on what
I really want to
shoot.
I think for all of you who have day jobs,
that's
a nice luxury to be able to have a lot of
photographers.
A lot of professional photographers they don't
have that luxury.
They have to say, "Well, OK, I'm shooting
these weddings."
Last
night on our show we interviewed Scott Jarvie
who's a
professional wedding photographer.
He's gotta do his weddings and he's gotta
do this.
He does other stuff
but I think I've got a luxury to be able to
shoot sort of
whatever I want, which is nice.
So I'm going to also go
through some pictures up here while we talk,
in general.
And sort of talk about that.
We recently did a trip to
Death Valley.
Had a great time.
There are a number of
Googlers on there including our own Brian
Rose, his wife Kim, out on the
playa . There's some more pictures.
That's Lotus
Carroll, my co-host.
Some of you may know Vincent doing a big jump
out on the playa.
This was a playa called the Racetrack.
And beautiful colors in Death Valley.
So I'm going to go through some pictures,
as well.
You
know, the first thing as far as time goes,
you know the
question I get a lot is how do you do your
job?
How do
you do your kids and how do you still have
so much time
to take photos?
The first thing is, the camera goes with
me everywhere.
If you're serious about photography and
you want to take it up on the side in addition
to your
job, I would say, being able to carry that
camera with you everywhere
is a good place to start.
I take this backpack with me a
lot of places which has all of my lenses as
well so I'm a
little hard core with it.
But even if it's just a
Micro Four Thirds or smaller camera or just
a digital SLR and a
zoom lens, something like that.
I think carrying it everywhere
you go.
I find I'll steal time.
I live in the East Bay
and I work in San Francisco.
So if I'm going to take the
BART home, I'll purposely backtrack on the
BART so I can
get a seat so I can be processing photos the
entire time.
I
try to make the most efficient use for photography
of all
of my time that I'm not working or with my
family or
kids.
So a big part of that is thinking about that
as
your day.
If I'm going to have some exercise.
Yesterday
I was going to take a walk.
So you know walk around with
the camera in San Francisco.
Take it out do an impromptu
photo walk all by yourself.
I find if you incorporate
other areas of your life like commuting.
Sometimes when
you're driving you can't process when you're
driving.
If
you're commuting; if you're exercising, anything
you do
find time to do that.
As far as my project for the 100
largest American cities, I think we all travel.
And
when I took on this project, I knew that I
wasn't going
to have a lot of time in individual cities.
So I wanted
to figure out how I could most efficiently
shoot those
cities.
And the first thing I do before I go on a
trip
is I very carefully research exactly what
I'm going to
shoot.
I found Flickr is the best resource for that.
I'll usually get to a city.
I'll look for the city of
Chicago or the city of St. Louis.
I'll sort that by
interestingness on Flickr and I'll look at
a lot of what
other people have taken, interesting shots.
I'll get a
lot of my locations from that.
I'll use that as a
location scout.
A lot of the photos on Flickr are
geo-tagged.
If they're not geo-tagged, a lot of times
you can figure out
where they are anyways.
And with those points ahead of
my trip I'll make a Google map and I'll go
in and I'll
make the pinpoints of every place I'm going
to shoot in
that city and I don't always get to all of
them on that
map before I ever even leave.
In fact weeks before.
And
I'll also coordinate them.
So if there's something I
really, really want to shoot I'll use a different
kind of
pin.
If it's, "well, I'd like to get that; that'd
be nice", I might use a different pin.
So
before I ever leave, I got a very, very well
thought out
map of exactly what I'm going to shoot.
Once I go on the
trip, I'll coordinate my route so I hit a
lot of the
things in a row.
I don't want to waste any time.
I
sleep very little on the trip.
I usually do long
weekends so I'll do a Friday to Monday because
I can get
away from work during that time.
And I'll use every waking hour I can
possible focused on shooting this agenda that
I've mapped
out for myself.
I try to avoid driving during rush hour.
So if I know I'm going to be in a car, I'll
purposely
plan my trip around that.
I'll have places that I'm going to be walking
around shooting during rush hour.
I'll make the most of
my sunrises and sunsets.
If I'm going to go to Austin,
I want to shoot the Pennybacker Bridge at
sunrise.
I'll
be out there; I'll have that already set out.
So I have my sunsets and sunrises especially
planned.
Those are always oftentimes times around rush
hour traffic so you want to find a good, very
picturesque location to
shoot.
When I am, also when I plan on the trips I
think
back up is very important.
I learned early on that inevitably,
for whatever reason, you end up losing photos
on trips.
I
don't know what it is.
It's the one time the hard drive goes bad.
It's the one time something goes wrong.
Your memory card malfunctions.
You accidentally
format your card when you thought you had
got all your photos
off but you didn't.
So there's a lot of mistakes you could
make.
I bring with me just a little one terabyte
FireWire 800 Seagate portable drive, I don't
remember what they're called, but they're
not that
expensive and I use that as a Time Machine
drive on my
Mac.
So everything gets backed up as I go.
So if I lose
stuff I'll be able to get it back.
I have lost stuff; I've
got it back.
Even recently in Death Valley.
I went to bed and
I thought all the photos had been copied.
I thought they
were and I took the card off in the morning
and I
reformatted and I used it and I realized I
missed 200 photos
at the end of my Racetrack.
So I had to use card recovery
software to get them back.
So I was able to get them
back so you can even when you format a card
you can still
almost every time get the pictures back with
recovery
software.
But you have to be very mindful of losing
pictures.
Particularly if you're going to go on a trip
you're going to take 10, 12, 13, 15 thousand
photographs.
You
want to make sure that they're backed up so
I clear out a
lot of space on my hard drive on my Mac.
I got a 750 gigabyte hard drive internally
lot so I make sure I have a lot of room
there.
I have a Time Machine drive that backs up
everything.
I've got a formula where every night when
I
come in at the end of every night I have to
religiously
do certain things.
One is I have to make sure all my cards
are off loaded.
I don't use Adobe Lightroom to off load
my cards and import it, although I might do
that at home.
Because it's slower.
I just drag and drop them.
From
this is a date folder to a date folder as
fast as I can.
I got a 64 gigabyte card; I've got to get
a lot of pictures off.
I won't have time; I want to go to sleep.
I also steal time during the day.
You do get tired.
You can't go 20 hours straight.
So you
need bathroom breaks.
You need water breaks.
Starbucks,
I use a lot of times for that.
Starbucks is great
because they're consistent.
You know they're going to
have a bathroom.
[laughter] You know they're going to have
coffee and caffeine
which I live on.
You know they're going to have water.
So I'll plan that.
And they usually have power.
And
they have wifi.
So free wifi.
So it's very, very
consistent.
So whatever I think about their coffee, it
kind of
doesn't matter.
I'll get a little coffee and just you know
focus on my stuff and get it done on a break.
But to use all that
time efficiently while I'm having coffee.
While I go to
the bathroom.
Not while I'm going to the bathroom unless
somebody's watching my computer and stuff
or they'll steal it.
But
you know I'll make sure that I get those pictures
off
during the day and then reformat the card
and keep using it.
At the end of the day, that needs to be done.
The
batteries need to be charged.
I keep three fully charged
batteries.
But the end of the day I'm putting one in.
It's the last thing I do before I go to bed.
Make sure
you got a fully charged battery the next morning.
That's
sort of my routine.
Every night do that.
Then you're ready
fresh for the next day.
Have the bag packed have it
ready for sunrise.
Yeah, question?
>>Male #1: Do you travel by yourself or with
people?
>> Thomas Hawk: Well, that's a good question.
I do travel by myself
sometimes.
I can be very efficient.
A lot of times I travel with people.
So
speaking of people, that's another point.
When I am
preparing my trip.
I mention I make a map.
Another
thing I do frequently is I'll go, and this
is usually in
Flickr, but I'll go to the local Flickr user
group for
that town.
So maybe it's Detroit, maybe it's Miami.
There's inevitably a group focused in that
area.
And
I'll say, "hey, I'm coming to town."
And I have found
almost every town I've gone to I've ended
up hooking up
with some locals.
And in addition to all the stuff I can
find on Flickr and map out, locals are fantastic.
Because oftentimes, if you
look at their work and see what they're shooting.
My friend
Michelle, who's down in Miami, who I'd never
met before.
I
kind of knew her online.
We were kind of friends.
We became really good
friends when I went down in Miami.
She has all these
great abandoned spots.
We're shooting this old abandoned
boat racing amphitheater.
It's graffiti everywhere.
And we're up on the roof of it.
And
you get great shots and all of that.
I find by finding locals -- oops, must verify
the account,
uh, Google music manager.
[laughter] I like Google music by the way.
So I'm going to flip through a few more of
these while we
talk.
But I find locals are very, very helpful.
Look for
locals.
One thing I hope at some point I'm able to
do
better with Google+.
I created at one point in Google+ a little
post created a
Google map hey if you're on Google+ put yourself
on
this map.
We don't really have anything like that right
now in
Google+ but I'd love that.
I would love to be able to say I'm going to
go to
Detroit.
Who are all the photographers in Detroit?
Who
are all the photographers in New York?
Who are all the
photographers in Kansas City?
So I can hook up with them
when I go to these trips and say hey let's
hang out.
Let's go shoot this or that.
I went to Toronto.
Which
isn't an American city but I like to think
of the
Canadians as almost Americans.
No, just kidding.
Canadians are great.
[laughter] Canadians are like the
most politest people in the world.
I had a great
time shooting Toronto.
When I went up to Toronto, I hooked
up with this guy Toms who's a roof-topper.
We're sitting
up there.
We're going up on these roofs in Toronto,
stories high, setting our tripods, getting
some of the most
amazing night scenes that you've ever seen.
And with the
CN tower and stuff like that.
So you'd never have access
to that without a local.
So I find before I go on the
trip I mean all of this takes planning.
Get to know some
of the local people.
Get to know the local user group.
Sometimes the locals don't always want to
share but a lot
of them do.
When I went to Detroit, a lot of them -- and
I say "hey I'm coming to Detroit."
They say, "you're just
going to shoot abandoned stuff.
That's terrible.
We
don't want people shooting abandoned stuff."
But you
know you go to Detroit, you got to shoot abandoned
stuff.
[laughter]
So you know, they're kind of sensitive to
that in
Detroit.
So you got to kind of feel out the locals.
Feel what they want to do.
I find that having a group
and going with a group is helpful sometimes.
Small
group.
I've shot cities all by myself, too.
I went to
Memphis, shot by myself, but went with on
other guy.
So
Sean Davis who's a local in Memphis and knows
a lot about
it.
He knew a lot of spots.
On top of the Peabody Hotel.
Speaking of hotels before you
go -- I like to look at where are all the
view spots?
Where can you get up high in the city?
So do a little
bit of research.
Is there a bar?
In San Francisco, our own city up here, you
can get to the top of the Marriott; there's
a great view from up there.
They have a bar up there.
There are some places you can get on top of
the Mandarin
Hotel in San Francisco.
Which has a wonderful view down
on the TransAmerica building.
So hotels are also great
for getting on the top of because a lot of
times you can get
into a hotel.
It's not like an office building where they've
got security and everything.
And you can frequently find
your way onto a roof.
I find -- I know this sounds
crazy.
I find 50, 60 times and yes, you're probably
technically trespassing and all that, but
50, 60 percent
of the time you can get on most hotel roofs
and those are some
great places to take shots.
We'll do some of those from
the roofs and stuff sometimes.
I think if I do go to a city and do
a photo walk and I do a lot of photo walks.
I've
probably done 125 photo walks.
I'll go and schedule that
if it's a big photo walk for one night for
like three or
four hours.
Because it's really hard on big photo walks
to really focus on shooting a city.
You can't shoot it; they're more of a social
thing.
But if I do a photo walk in a city, but if
you get too many people?
We went on a
trip to Boston with some friends from Flickr
and there
were probably 20 people.
It was too big.
It was too many.
You can't keep track of
everybody.
You kind of lose people.
So I think -- but I
think planning the trip, having everything,
having a
route, having everything on Google map before
you go.
When I am there, there's no time to be online.
You know,
I'm not going to be socializing.
I got to focus on
shooting.
I'm not going to be processing.
You have to
resist the urge to process.
You just took all these
great shots.
And you're like oh, I just got a sunrise.
I want to process it get it online.
It's so cool.
I want to do it right now.
You
can't.
You got to focus shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot,
shoot, shoot.
There
will be time for that later.
I know in Death Valley it
was like oh boy we just shot this Racetrack.
I
want to process them.
Resist the temptation.
I think
[pause] Oh, one of the other things I do if
I'm driving
and I have my route in addition to having
it on a map and
on the phone I actually print it out and print
it by the
address in order of what I'm going to shoot.
So I
actually have a printout.
In case all of a sudden you wont' be able
to connect on the internet or something happens
and you can't get it.
I think having a printout helps as well.
I think considering bundling trips
is also a great way to do it.
I'll shoot Nashville and
Memphis.
Austin and Houston.
Cities that are close
together to try to maximize the travel time.
As far as
post processing goes, you know, that's a big
part of it.
I use Lightroom to process my photos but I
don't have a
lot of time.
You have to go very, very quickly.
If I'm
going to publish a million photos, my goal
is I have to
process at least 350 photos a week.
And if I'm gone the
weekend before because I'm doing a shoot,
that means 700 the next weekend.
So you got
to power through them and you can't spend
more than a
couple minutes on a shot.
These are some shots I took at
the Decompression Event recently in the city,
in San Francisco.
Sort
of a Burning Man in the City sort of thing.
I love
shooting people.
These are all sort of
interesting-looking people that were at this
thing.
And
I shoot anything and everything.
I shoot people, I shoot
landscapes.
I shoot nature.
Flowers.
I shoot concerts.
Sure.
>> Male #2: So how do you get -- [inaudible]
>> Thomas Hawk: Right.
Well, because I'm not concerned at all about
the
economics of this business, I don't get model
releases
because I'm not going to sell it as a stock
picture.
And
you can still publish it as a photograph and
you can
certainly even still put it in a magazine
or newspaper if
it's editorial or if it's fine art.
The courts have
ruled if it's a fine art photograph, it also
qualifies as a
no-release.
I don't bother with releases at all.
I find it kind of depends on what I'm shooting
and where I'm shooting and how I'm shooting.
And an
event like this, people are into it.
They're getting
dressed up because they want to kind of show
off.
You
see this guy.
You still ask his permission.
"can I get
your picture?"
"yeah, yeah, yeah."
These are shot with a
fish-eye, 8 to 13 millimeter fish-eye, so
I am this close to his nose.
So I got to warn him.
And
I say "hey I'm going to be getting real close
here just so
you're not freaked out".
Fine.
So and the fish eye are
some new lens I got.
I've kind of been going crazy with
it.
So you can get super close.
So one I did to get
people is find festivals and events like this.
So
Decompression in the City.
Burning Man happens every
year, I've never gone, actually, myself, but
I'm gonna be going this year.
But you know parades.
You know the Gay Pride
parade in San Francisco.
Any sort of events like that.
I found the vast protests.
Protests are great.
I was
shooting the Occupy San Francisco protest
yesterday.
I
mean, you can get right in the cop's face
with the
camera, right in the protester's face with
the camera.
You can get some compelling, engaging portraits.
This
guy, by the way, was completely naked except
he was covered in silver.
I'm not going to
show you the picture from lower down, [laughter]
but we'll avoid
that one.
But I find that you know you can -- a lot
of
these -- a lot of places like that.
Other times though
I'm just shooting street.
I'm out on the street I got
the camera.
It's bam, bam, bam, bam, bam.
You're not asking
permission.
You don't want to ask permission.
You --,
you know, comic book conventions.
Stuff like this.
To
get great portraits of interesting people.
You know,
this was at ComicPalooza in Houston.
So you know places
like this and then I've got Superman there.
So I think
you can look for those if you want to take
interesting
pictures of people.
I do a 2 dollar portrait series
where anybody who asks me for money.
Oops, camera fell.
Anybody that asks me for
money I started it a couple years ago I'll
take your
portrait for two dollars.
I'll give you two dollars to
take your portrait.
I found that wasn't even so much a
photography driven project.
As much as it was when I
first came to San Francisco I was right out
of college.
People would ask me for spare change.
Here you go here
you go.
And after awhile like jeez this is all the
time.
And you know I kind of started resenting it
and pretty
soon I stopped giving them money.
And pretty soon I
started avoiding people and I didn't like
that being out
on the street and avoiding people.
So one day I was in
Portland shooting on the Burnside Bridge.
I think it's Burnside, I think it's
called.
And I was having my headphones on as I was
shooting.
A
lot of times I listen to music and this guy
homeless-looking guy was kind of walking past
me and he
said something to me.
And I said I'm sorry I don't have
any money because I assumed he was asking
for that.
And the guy got very agitated.
And I
stopped.
I hadn't heard him so I took my headphones
off and said "I'm sorry".
I wasn't asking few you for
money.
I want to know if you'd take my picture.
And I
just felt like a jerk.
What a jerk I was.
And so, I
felt really bad I ended up taking the guy's
picture.
It
was kind of a moment for me when I said if
I'm out here
being on the street and part of the street,
I need to treat
people with respect and I can't be doing that.
So I said
I'm going to turn this aversion I have to
people asking me for
money into a photography project and I started
my 2
dollar portrait project.
And I've taken a number of
photographs now of individuals and I also
usually publish a
story.
Here's one right here.
I publish a story about
the individuals.
And I get a little bit about them and I
talk to them as a human being.
Hey, what's your story?
Do you have kids?
And do you want to do this project?
95 percent of the time they do want to do
the project.
They say, "yeah, that's great."
Terrific.
And they're
thankful and grateful.
That's another place I get
portraits.
You find them in odd ways.
Sometimes you find an
interesting guy in the street and I'll just
go up to him and say, "hey, can I
take your picture?"
A lot of times they say no.
You
know, but a lot of times they say yes.
So I'll do
portraits like that.
And sometimes I shoot street just
shoot randomly.
Every now and then you get somebody who
gets very angry with you.
You just kinda got to.
Henri Cartier-Bresson used the term shoot
and scram too.
Sometimes you shoot and scram.
You gotta take off.
But I
think -- if you really look for it there's
really enough
events that you can find.
These are shots that I took in
Houston.
I love shooting street art and graffiti so
I
look for that ahead of time.
Look for where the graffiti
yards are and go shoot a lot of that; that's
temporal.
This is just a street shot so she didn't know
I was taking her photograph.
I just bam took it.
So sometimes I'll just take
photographs, too.
I love cemeteries.
I'll shoot in cemeteries.
There's wonderful
statuary you can find sometimes.
Here's a weeping angel, I think it's in Evergreen
Cemetery, maybe, Houston.
--Yeah?
>> Female #1: So one of the things to do [inaudible].
>> Thomas Hawk: Yeah.
Sometimes you know I will shoot from the hip
so
to speak.
There are some reasonably rough areas in San
Francisco that I've shot like the Tenderloin
whatnot
where I know there's an active drug deal going
right
there.
You're watching the crack change hands and
I've gotten some photos of those.
I'm
careful how I publish those these days.
I got called
into court after shooting the Oakland riots
and had to
get subpoenaed and had to go to court and
do a lot of stuff.
. I wasn't too crazy
about that.
Because I was taking pictures of looters
that were looting out in the Oakland riots.
A lot of
times when I am shooting from the hip I'll
actually have
the camera around my neck and I'll hold it
cable release connected
in my pocket.
And so, you want to shoot at something like
F
8 or big wide aperture.
"F 8 and be there" as a photo
journalist say.
So you want to have a lot of room for
your focus so if you're getting it wrong you're
still
getting it because you're not looking through
the view
finder.
And I'll shoot with cable release and just
walk around and shoot stuff.
A lot of times
you'll get stuff that's not worth using.
I don't like to
do that a lot.
I like to use the view finder.
I'll only
do that when I am in a sketchy area where
there's not an
easy way to be out there like this.
If there's a drug
deal going down and you're [laughter] You
might not have
your camera or your life.
They usually don't like being
photographed.
But it is street.
>> Male #3: [inaudible question]
>> Thomas Hawk: What do you mean?
Terms of service?
Like how?
Oh.
There's just another street photograph.
But yeah, so
well, speaking of that.
So we'll get into that a little
bit too.
We'll talk about photo sharing sites.
So I
started out with Flickr.
That's probably the big site
that I was on.
First of all, I'm a fan of joining every
site.
I think as far as a photographer.
If my goal is
to be seen by as many people as possible and
be published in as many places as possible.
. I want to be on
Flickr, I want to be on Twitter, I want to
be on
Facebook I want to be on Google+.
I also think
though that you pick a site as your sort of
primary
social place where you are gonna interact.
For me that's Google
plus.
I think that's the most superior platform
for photographers right
now.
[applause] We like Google +.
And Google+, I've written a number of blog
posts on it.
You guys are doing, you
know, I think everything right for photographers.
And
it's been so refreshing because before Google+
I
really think Flickr was sort of the game in
town.
Flickr had a lot of problems which we'll go
through a
little bit.
But Google+ is a terrific place for
photographers.
Terrific resource.
The photo pages look
great.
The big photos and Lightbox look great.
There's
tremendous engagement.
There's a great strong community
thanks to your leaders and community managers
like
Natalie and like Brian.
People that are out there
engaging the community.
And not just them.
People like
Ricardo.
People who aren't necessarily community managers.
There's a lot of people in Google who seem
very
enthused by photos and are part of that.
On our Death
Valley trip I don't know I think there were
probably ten
Googlers that went on the trip.
So Gerard, you were there and Vega was there.
So we had a great trip.
So I
think Google is really sort of shown a commitment
to
photography.
From my perspective, you want to go also
where things are going, not where things have
been.
So
to go back to Flickr a little bit.
Have I gotten into
trouble.
I've gotten into a lot of trouble on Flickr
both in
terms of service type issues.
Some of which were kind of
stupid.
Other issues which were more personal in matter.
You know with Flickr I was banned from their
help forum
for about two years.
I was blacklisted from Explore!
They claim they didn't have a blacklist which
is the
section where they promote people but they
personally
blacklisted me out of it as a user.
I was critical of
Flickr.
And I think I took the wrong approach with
Flickr initially.
So I'm never going to be critical of
Google+.
[laughter] I think the problem with
Flickr is early on because I was a very early
user
before Yahoo ever bought them, before anything.
I'd banter back and forth
with Stuart and we'd argue and fight and things
like that.
Stewart Butterfield was one of the co-founders
of Flickr.
There were
things that I thought that Flickr should have.
Like the
very, very first thing I thought Flickr should
have was
track backs.
Everybody is getting these views on our
photos.
We don't know where they're coming from.
Flickr is capturing this data, why can't you
give it to
us?
Well, if we give it to you, there will be
Spam Well, No.
I don't understand that.
How
can there be Spam?
It's just a referral URL.
You're sharing with us.
Flickr did eventually give us
that.
But I think in doing that, you know I would
find
things that I didn't like about Flickr and
I'd sometimes
be more abrasive than I should have, I think,
in hindsight.
And
particularly Flickr had a practice for a long
time if an
account was deleted, it was deleted.
It was gone.
There was no
getting it back.
And so, you know, I had content
removed.
I was an administrator of a group called Delete
Me Uncensored which was kind of a failed experiment
now
in hindsight which I probably shouldn't have
been involved in so much.
But it was kind of a voting game in a group
but it was also
uncensored forum.
So you say whatever you want.
And you
know people would say whatever they want.
And there
would end up being harassment in there to
the point
Flickr nuked our group one time.
I ran a lot afoul with
terms of service.
And Flickr's were very, very broad.
They were "don't be that guy" whatever that
means.
I've
had content.
I had a huge content battle that I can't
really talk too much about because I was sued
and I had
to settle so part of the settlement terms
is
confidentiality agreement but with the erotic
art museum
down in Miami where I took some pictures.
They ended up
but I can't get too much into it.
So I've had some sort
of problems like that in the past.
That I'm not going to
have on Google+.
[chuckles] I think one of my
strategies is to be a factory and be a machine.
I
describe myself as a photography factory sometimes.
Which is to
publish every single day.
Schedule publish so I publish
five five posts to Google+ you know, one in
the early
morning, one in the mid-morning, one about
noon or one, one in the afternoon, one
in the early evening.
I've got them all picked out
already so I've got this folder right here
which has
about 9,000 photographs in it that I've already
selected.
So these are photos that I like enough to
publish.
And
so, you know, they'll be -- and every day
I just pull
from this folder a different photo kind of
at random.
And I want the photos to be kind of at random
also
because over time --
over time I want there to be
diversity in my photo stream.
So I want some San Francisco,
some Chicago, all over the United States,
different places in
time.
So I just pick every day.
And then I up load.
Right now I'm up loading like 40 a day to
Flickr.
And
so, I'll publish more there.
With Flickr my strategy is
to publish my best five last because that's
only what people
see on Flickr.
They don't see the other ones.
Another
strategy I think with online, I mentioned
Delete Me
Uncensored.
I'm at the point now, where you just have
to avoid toxic people.
There
are toxic people out there.
And one of the things that's
really nice about Google+ is there's a very
robust
block feature.
I've already seen a lot on Google+
even but I'll see there's Elena Kalis has
this guy that
just rips into her all the time.
Oh, she's a terrible
underwater photographer.
Why do people like her.
And
you know take a guy like that boom, gone,
block.
You don't see him; you never
see him again.
I had a guy the other day came on my
photo stream, you're the worst photographer
I've ever
seen ever, ever.
I'm replying back -- really?
The worst?
The
absolute worst?
[laughter] There's nobody worse than me?
"no, no
you are the worst."
Trey has some HDR haters.
You guys know Trey Ratcliff.
You're
destroying photography.
You're ruining 100 years of what
photography is all about.
You just block them.
So now
I'm at the point where I just block.
That's by the way a
weakness of Flickr.
If you block somebody on Flickr,
that means they can't comment on your photos
but they can
still comment on the groups you're in.
They can still
follow your friends and comment on there.
And you have to
still see it.
The nice thing about Google+ is you
wipe somebody out, they're out; they're gone.
That's a good thing.
That's something I've learned with photographing
online.
There
are some things Flickr does really right I
think.
And
that I think Google really should take a look
at and some
places where I think they are doing it right.
I think
it's easy to blog and embed their photos right
there from
the photo.
You can get an embed code and put it on your
blog.
Now I've been blogging some of my Google+
photos but I've had to custom create that
HTML and so
myself and put that code in there.
You can go to Picasa and get
some but it looks wonky and it doesn't look
good.
That's
a thing they do very well.
I think groups have been a success
there but they have never capitalized on them.
Interestingness was an interesting idea to
rank photos by
social activity and the meta data around them.
Flickr even
got a patent on it which I can't believe they
got a
patent on that.
You know they had the API.
They were
there early.
The Flickr blog they do a good job.
The
sign in accounts with Facebook and Google
I thought was a great move
that they did.
25 dollars for an unlimited photos is a
great deal.
In fact I think Google should think about
that.
Google has, you know right now, at least with
Picasa,
it's based on how much storage you use.
So you know I
think for somebody like me would end up costing
me
potentially.
If I had the same amount as I do on Flickr
about 500 dollars a year or something like
that.
I don't think really that's
the best model.
Photographers that are popular that are
putting a lot of photographs on there, even
if they are big.
I
think you want them.
You want that content on the site.
So you want to encourage it.
Flickr's 25 for all you
can publish I think is a good deal.
Flickr's got the
Getty deal which is 20 percent payout which
is terrible
which Google can totally rock that.
Because 20 percent
payout to photographers is terrible.
Google could do
something with stock.
It's a multi-billion dollar
business.
I mention it a lot.
But it is something with
Flickr that they have that's an advantage
because I get
paid you know 500 bucks a month just for having
an
account on Flickr so I'm actually getting
paid because
of this Getty thing and people buy my images
and use them
on Getty.
I don't really have to do anything.
Here you
go.
Here's 200 of my images.
Use them.
And Getty
markets them.
Getty sells them.
People find them
through Getty.
I think Google should maybe think about
something like that.
Organization.
That I think the way
they have albums is better.
You can use super setter.
So I have 1600 albums at Flickr sets.
And I can say, anything that's
got this keyword in Occupy San Francisco on
this date do
this.
Make it a set.
And it just automatically does it.
It's kind of like smart play lists with iTunes.
I think
it's a smart way to do album management.
What Flickr is
doing wrong.
Innovation is completely stalled.
I don't
know if you guys saw the latest products they
just
released.
One is like an android app which is pretty
awful.
The other one is they had this thing where
I can connect
up with another Flickr user and we can look
at this
Flickr photo and chat with each other.
It's like who's
going to use that?
Nobody's going to use that.
I mean,
we got hangouts at Google+.
I can have all these
people in a room and show the picture right
there and people can see
it.
So you know I mention they have bad blocking
tools.
Ability to -- you know, the other issue that's
come up a
little bit with Google and is sort of a controversial
hot
button and I don't know the answer and I'm
sure you guys
are all smart and thinking about it.
What do you do
about adult-oriented content?
Some people say that's a
very easy question.
What Flickr has done is they've
just created filters.
So if I want to do adult-oriented
content, I'll mark it as adult-oriented content.
If
people opt into that thing then they can see
it and if
they don't, then they don't see it.
And it's filtered
out.
And that will work.
I don't think that's worked
for Flickr.
And I think that what's happened at Flickr
is there's this ginormous underside that a
lot of people
don't see because safe search is on by default
so a lot
of users don't see it.
But there's a huge amount of
giant underground porn on Flickr and it's
all amateur
based porn.
And I don't know that you want that.
I
don't think you want to be -- I certainly
don't think
Google wants to be associated with that.
I doubt Yahoo
wants to be associated with it.
I don't think they
necessarily meant for that to happen.
But on the other
hand, what do you do about somebody who might
be a little cutting
edge, who might show a little bit of nipple
because of
fine art photograph and something that probably
should be
allowed to be shared between two consenting
adults and
it's art.
So that's a line and I don't know what the
answer is but you know that's something else
to think
about.
So with that, that's kind of what I wanted
to
talk about with my own photography a little
bit as well
as some of these other sites Flickr and Google+.
I've got some of my Google+ photos that I
published
recently too.
That's in Seattle -- Seattle Central
Library which has wonderful architecture.
That's another one from Death Valley.
Lotus
Carroll who does the show with me.
That was just -- I took
that photograph yesterday of a police line
at Occupy San
Francisco where they arrested three people
in the street
that were blocking Market Street.
You know, I do a lot
of out of focus work.
Man that drives people nuts.
[laughter] I
put that stuff on Google+, "did you forget
your
glasses?
Were you drinking?
This is the view I see when
I get out of the bar."
You know, it's certainly an
aesthetic.
Sometimes people really hate it.
It's a
police officer the morning after Occupy San
Francisco
when they cleared him out of there.
It's an
architectural building at Fort Worth.
Again, this is
something on my pinpoint.
This was a point on my map.
I wanted to shoot the Modern
which is the modern art museum in Fort Worth.
Beautiful
architecture.
There's a picture of Scott Jarvie.
I'll
go crazy with the photo processing sometimes.
That's a
mirror effect down the middle.
A shot in Sacramento in
the rain with neon signs.
I collect neon signs.
I got
about 10,000 photos with neon signs.
Botanical garden
in St. Louis is the best botanical garden
I've ever been to
any place in my life.
Wonderful stuff to shoot there.
There are
two of my children.
That's Kate and Holly in a
tunnel down in Los Angeles.
Cable cars.
Love graffiti
too.
So questions.
>>Male #4: [inaudible]
>> Thomas Hawk: Sure.
>>Thomas Hawk: I think very little of it is
having multi-thousand
dollar camera and lens and all that.
I think you can
take pictures with a camera phone and do interesting
things with it.
To start with you know a lot of people
probably wouldn't say this and wouldn't even
like me
saying this.
I think 60 to 70 percent of it is processing.
So I think it kind of doesn't matter what
camera you're
using.
The stuff you can do today in Lightroom the
way
you can change a photograph and what you can
do with it
there a huge amount of it is in the processing.
Particularly if you're publishing online,
you don't
necessarily need a mega-resolution picture.
It only can
be so big online.
And people are going to see it.
You're not making prints of it necessarily
when you're
starting out, I don't think.
So I think just getting any
camera and shooting.
I do think DSLRs, you can do things
with DSLRs you can't do with a camera phone.
But
a lot of people say I'm starting out I want
to buy a
DSLR.
Which one should I buy?
Should I buy this Canon 5D Mark II, brand
new from B and H
and I'll say no.
You're starting out.
Go to Ebay and
buy a used 20 D for you know 600 bucks and
get yourself a
50 millimeter F 18 for less than 100 bucks
and go out and
shoot with a cheap thing.
If you like it and you're into it, you can
always sell that thing back on Ebay and not
lose any money and then go out and buy a Canon
5 D Mark II when you're ready.
It's kind of like I decided a
number of years ago I was going to play golf
which I hate
golf.
[laughter] I don't know what I was thinking.
I mean golf
course how many pictures can you take of a
golf course.
So I went out and bought these Ping golf clubs.
These are
nice.
Oh yeah, I'm going to make a better golfer
with
these Pings.
You know, and I think I used them twice.
I
ended up selling them back lost a bunch of
money because
I bought them new and stuff like that.
So I think with
the camera stuff, too, buy something used,
I think, even.
Buy
you know just a very basic setup see if you
like it then
you can always go from there.
I think a lot of it is the
processing.
A lot of it is the eye and the time.
Getting what you get.
Another question back there?
>> Male #5: [inaudible]
>> Thomas Hawk: Okay.
Yeah.
I've got a lot of photographs.
So many
photographs that, you know, I have at this
point over one
million frames of raw files.
So Lightroom can't really
manage that many.
It just bogs down and goes too slow.
So
what I do.
Everything for any day is in a folder by that
day.
So 2011 hyphen 12 hyphen 08 and everything
from
that day goes in that folder and I keep everything
on to
be processed and I'm two years behind on my
processing
right now.
So I'm working on basically January 2010
right now is how far behind.
But I do jump forward and
do some Death Valley shots and things like
that.
So I do skip ahead a little bit
sometimes.
But for the most part I've got my to be
processed and my archived.
And my to be processed are
all in folders by dates.
I'll bring them to my Mac.
I'll import them into my Lightroom.
I'll work on them;
I'll save the file.
The catalog file for that folder
once I make my changes in the Lightroom.
Export those
files as JPEG.
Then it goes in my archive folder.
So I
already done that day.
And then I'll just keep them by
dates and bring them on my hard drive as I
process them
then take them back off when I am done.
Question?
>>Male #6: [inaudible]
>> Thomas Hawk: I
only shoot raw.
I don't really see any reason to shoot
JPEG myself.
I'm going to process everything.
I can do
more with a raw file than I can with a JPEG
file.
Particularly I believe a lot of it is in the
post
production.
That scene did not look like that when I
took that picture.
These were taken seconds apart but
they still look very different.
But I have a lot more things I
can do with raw files.
This is actually the exactly same
frame that looks three ways, actually four
ways.
This is
exact same raw file for all four of those
photographs.
So other questions?
>> Male #6: Do you shoot typically resolution
to keep the files.
>> Thomas Hawk: No.
I shoot at the highest possible raw resolution.
Storage is so cheap these days there's just
no reason why
even a 64.
I can put a 64 gigabyte card in my camera.
They're not that much money.
I can off load it; hard drives are cheap.
There's just no reason not
to get the best stuff.
And I don't throw any files away
even if I don't like the file.
I save it because you may
be able to do something with it in the future.
A lot of
my shots from three years ago, "ah, that's
too noisy; I
don't want it."
And then Adobe Lightroom 3 comes out
with this great noise reduction technology
so now all of
a sudden I can salvage some old shots.
Question?
>>Male #7: [inaudible] How do you get colors
on Google+?
>> Thomas Hawk: Google+?
>> Male #: Places like -- none of my friends
are actually.
I
have friends.
[inaudible]
>> Thomas Hawk: What you do is you show up
to Vic Gundotra's office with a big
suitcase full of money [laughter].
>> Female #2: True story.
>> Thomas Hawk: No.
You know, I mean, obviously I am on the
recommended user list for Google+ and that
adds a lot
of people.
As far as Google+ goes I did get on very
very early.
You know, I obviously I was very interested
in this photography space.
I've been down here having
lunch with Brian a year before Google+ even
launched.
Having no idea what you guys were up to even.
But I've
had a huge interest.
I was a big user on Google Buzz
photography.
I was very interested in photography with
Google.
So I know when Brian invited me to the site
the
day it was open for the beta so I jumped right
on.
I
said this is great.
I love it.
So I basically went to
my network which is a lot of people on the
social photo
sharing space on Flickr, on Twitter, on everywhere
else, and said hey you've
got to get here.
Blog posts.
So I pulled I think a lot
of my own friends, photographer friends, into
Google+.
And I got on early so I was able to build
up an early
following and circles get shared so you're
in
those and you get more and then you guys did
the recommended user list and so
I'm on that as a photographer.
So I think you know
there's a lot of ways that you end up with
a lot of
followers.
Certainly the recommended list is a huge
thing.
I mean Trey and I both are on the picks sections
of that list.
That accounts for a lot of people.
I
think being active, too.
People want to see you active on
the site.
They want to see you in hangouts.
They want
to see you an active part of the community.
We're doing
this new hangout videocasts stuff like that
is great.
Visibility.
But just being active.
You know and I had a
big following coming in.
So I had you know -- nowhere
near the number of followers in Google but
I was one of
the most followed accounts on Flickr, for
instance.
So I
had all these people I could evangelize to
Google+
and say come on over.
So I was able to bring in a lot of
these people.
Sort of have a head start where somebody's
just starting out they don't have a big network
to bring
in.
So I think those were kind of all factors.
I'm very
active on it.
Question?
>>Male #8: [inaudible]
>> Thomas Hawk: Yeah.
I like Lightroom.
I think Lightroom is
pretty easy.
There's a lot of online tutorials that are
free that will show you how to do it.
I think spend some
time.
Even some of the stuff these like hangouts
on
Google+.
Hang out with Scott Jarvie.
Scott Jarvie
is an easy guy to get a hold of.
He hangs out all
the time.
Look for Scott Jarvie on a hangout even if
he's not processing.
Scott's like processing like 50
percent of the time and he hangs out all the
time but
just say hey Scott, you mind processing this
photo?
And
he'll be like yeah sure, and there you go.
[laughter] And he'll
jump right in.
And he's very good.
But you can see and
go, "hey, what did you just do there?
What did you brush
there?"
I think Lightroom.
There's a lot of people that
will spend eight hours on a photograph.
They'll bring it
into PhotoShop.
They'll do 18 different layers.
They'll do all kinds of things.
I don't do that.
Guys
like Jarvie don't do that.
I think that, you know, I think
that you can pick it up on tutorials.
You can pick it up
online.
You can pick it up in the community.
So I think
just go with that way.
I think hangouts are a great way.
Other quick question?
>>Male #9: [inaudible]
>>Thomas Hawk: Yeah.
Again so much of it post processing.
I mean,
you can take a photograph, you know let's
say this
photograph right here.
And we can go to the develop
module and we can go up here to our temperature
on the
white balance and we can make it look like
this or we can
make it look like that.
Very hot; very cold.
You can
pretty much.
You have a lot of control after the fact
with that.
So a lot of this stuff, should I be on this
setting, should I be on that setting on the
camera.
A lot
of people kind of come in and say why did
you shoot that
ISO 800?
I mean ISO 800, 400, 200, 1600, what's the
difference.
Cannon 5 D Mark II can go up to 6400.
But there's really.
I
don't think in the camera actually matters
quite as much
as a lot of people do.
I think a lot of it can be done
in processing after the fact.
You know, I know a lot of
people will take more time and set up shots
and do
different things with stuff in camera but
I don't.
So
and, you know, again I think to learn processing
find some
interesting people.
Karen Hutton is here.
Hang out with
Karen.
Make her process a photo for you.
She's a master.
She's quite good.
You know.
She did a great shot of Lotus in
the car.
I don't know how you made her hair blow.
It
wasn't even really blowing in real life.
It's like we had a fan there or something.
>>Karen: [inaudible]
>>Thomas Hawk: There's some stuff . I don't
know what she did
there.
But, you know.
Yeah.
It's magic.
But find
people that you like their processing.
You'd be
surprised.
People ask me in hangouts all the time.
Will you
process a photo.
Sure.
I'll process this.
I don't
think processing is that hard.
I mean there are some
things you can do to be very, very complicated.
And make
it harder than it has to be.
But other questions?
>>Male #10: [inaudible]
>> Thomas Hawk: Okay.
Yeah.
You know.
And I have the same
problem.
Flagging takes a lot of time.
If I have a
shoot.
I wonder what I've got in my library right
now.
Yeah.
Nothing really worth showing there.
You know, if
I have a shoot -- yeah, I can take.
If I take 5,000
photographs and end up processing 1,000, the
time to go
through each 5,000 and flag them all.
I mean, there's
some ways you can speed that up a little bit.
Flash
memory in the computer instead of a regular
hard drive.
Things like that make Lightroom go a little
bit faster.
Make sure
you have enough ram.
8 Gigabytes of ram, to try to get it to go
a little bit faster.
>> Male #10: It's not the computer; it's the
decision making.
>> Thomas Hawk: That's true too.
That's just a manual process.
I think we all go
through that.
It's one of my least favorite parts of
processing.
Typically in a day I'll shoot anywhere on
a
trip anywhere from 3,000 to 6,000 frames and
to have to
go through those frames one by one and flag,
flag, flag.
But once you've got them flagged you can start
and
process them.
So
>>Male presenter: [inaudible] we have time
for one last question.
>> Male #11: [inaudible] What fraction of
the photos do you end up being able to keep?
>>Thomas Hawk: I probably keep 20 percent.
[several audience members respond inaudibly]
Yeah.
I keep about 20 percent.
Great.
Yeah, thanks for having me, guys.
I
really enjoyed it.
[Applause]